let me welcome all of you to I think
this is our 19th session in the series
of world of speculative fiction this one
is focused on Howard a Phillips
Lovecraft great the early 20th century
he prefer the term weird writer and I
think nowadays with class lines horror
but that really is grabbers fantasy and
science fiction as well just a giant in
the world of speculative fiction so this
this series we have some some new people
and very happy to see that this series
focuses on the narrative world and looks
at some of the philosophical themes
involved we have a lot of discussion and
back and forth we can stop at any time
and all I can do sometimes you get into
various digressions but that's okay I
have some some notes prepared but
they're usually fairly loose so anything
you want to say something or ask a
question or make a comment don't don't
feel shy about that I'm Greg Sandler I'm
a you could say local practicing and
public philosopher I was in academics
for a long time now I mean you can say
private practice but part of that is
doing public events like this
and the library has been hosting this
now for about it what about a year and a
half and the rest of the people here are
regulars in this so we've talked about a
number of really interesting thinkers
and what we usually do is we start out
with talking about some you know
biographical context and you know
literary context and then go into the
narrative world itself and then I
usually have some philosophical themes
picked out but it's rare that we don't
have other people bringing in some as
well so the ones that I picked for this
one there any Lovecraft is one of these
thinkers where you know we've almost got
an embarrassment of riches when it comes
to the themes the one that I picked out
were the notion of the weird tale is
Lovecraft slot
and then science rationalism and nature
cosmic pessimism describing the
indescribable which is something he
actually has a story where he's playing
her I would think that idea the funny
way a theme that I couldn't think of a
better way to phrase pickier way so I'm
just calling at why humans cooperate
with the sources of horror and then
we'll talk about if we have time about
love love these sort of the implications
of Lovecraft's racism and Anglophilia
which is pretty inescapable and stuff so
I've given you a timeline and some
quotes from some of his essays and works
that I think could be interesting before
we go into just a few general remarks so
I mentioned that Lovecraft is really a
giant and speculative fiction I don't
think that there's there's an author in
this sort of domain of weird weird tales
who has the stature that that he does in
puts so many other people one of the
books that I checked out just for fun
from the downtown library is this tales
of Cthulhu Mythos and I didn't get it
for the Lovecraft stuff again because
we've got all these other stories by if
it's HP Lovecraft and divers hands
so it's Lovecraft and August Derleth is
probably the biggest follower you can
say but also you know people like Fritz
Leiber we're going to talk about later
on down the line Carl Edward vogner or
philipose a farmer even Stephen King and
some of them are more successful I think
in turning their hand to the playing
around one crafting ideas some of my
lesson but you know you can ask well why
are these people why are they doing that
is it just you know can you know really
fascination with some obscure author
well
really somebody who influenced the whole
field of writers even have those outside
of or weird or supernatural fiction I
think some of what we see today because
some of the things would become perfect
pop culture you know like you can buy
yourself a Cthulhu knit cap right for
winter with the tentacle things like
that and there's Cthulhu for president
posters and bumper stickers every every
four years the slogan being vote for the
greater of the two sheets are looking
creatively bored but no white why did it
become such a fascinating thing well you
know there's something about Lovecraft
writings and I mention you know actually
get them a little bit of a soapbox so
ahem red dirt left before and I run down
and you know knew that he was probably
the most prolific author working with
Lovecraft's ideas and I was really
primed to appreciate him in part because
he also set a lot of the stories here in
Wisconsin right
and I you know I compared Lovecraft's
prose - barelifts prose dirt
unfortunately just couldn't measure up
there's something missing in the way
that he he does things there was
something a little bit overblown long
craft notes and he's nice I think a lot
of other people said his run is terrible
it's too much of this Larry Walker feels
like just up to the limit with the you
know cyclopean architecture and
non-euclidean geometry and indescribable
horrors and all these other things
goes right up to the limit and doesn't
go beyond it I think Derleth just wasn't
as good of a writer and I saw it a
little bit I mean what you know
wisconsin stories I was really primed to
for it to be really great but but it
didn't
to be so some of the other items that
were been more successful but they were
people who are very established in their
own right like Fritz Leiber or Philip
Jose farmer now I got into Lovecraft
myself I was trying to think about how
Hawaiian expense I think I started
reading and maybe in middle school I
don't think it was reading in elementary
school but I remember reading a lot of
Lovecraft stories back then and he's
somebody who had been returning to off
and on I suspect that I didn't really
understand 2/3 of what I was reading
back and it helped to learn something in
philosophy they actually make sense out
of what he was talking about at some
point so I'll try to get some of those
ideas here and there in a way that
hopefully be helpful Varian you know
very pleasantly surprised to find out
that my daughter who is a teenager has
been reading one craft for several years
about telling me about this summer
that's great
you know I don't know where she got the
idea from but apparently kids are
reading well correct so it's great you
know we have an older generation doing
it right it's going to live on and
actually be curious to find out - from
those of you diving - it was something
you just read for this time or longer
log scary luck that fans or maybe maybe
maybe not things may be bad but you're
you know drawn to reading them or for
some reason or it's a high school and
more for the themes I actually don't
really care for his narrative his prose
yeah they find it very difficult but I
find his ideas very interesting so the
ideas are worth enough to way through
the turgid prose yeah yeah you have the
same trionic say I
not having read much love graphs at all
- no I was laughing more because I've
heard that expressible philip k dick
ooo I'm not being very good but the
ideas are good oh yeah my mind was dig
it's more the opposite thing is already
very sparse yeah yeah exactly
okay it's not like moss hanging so
pretty at every dance yeah what what
about the rest of them I read them in
high school to another kind of [ __ ] name
perspective I thought that you were
beautiful rather than horrifying like
your Charlie what parade of weird stuff
and I think the weird stuff is
fascinating
yeah that's kind of the new weird wave
of writers and things to do they take
the ideas but write them yeah that's
actually did one we'll talk about that a
little bit why do I do that the unknown
has to be so so horrifying he sort of
seems to assume that only his characters
get fascinated right but that's always a
sign that there ought to be better we're
going to get in trouble did you get an
answer now you had a science fiction
course in many many years ago so it's
read several authors including some HP
Lovecraft but it's not current in my
mind - yeah flecked on you know what I
thought at that time comparative to
other writers it's interesting that they
included them in science fiction well I
think you know I mean it makes sense but
I think there's a lot of people who just
push them off in the more and that's
that's that
I didn't have know too much about him so
long learn more oh yeah well that's
excellent so let's talk about his his
wife you noticed it's not very long and
actually he lived in pretty crippling
poverty for a good portion of it
actually at the time that he died he was
you know living on rations that we would
see his central starvation stuff he's
born in Providence there's actually a
Lovecraft Museum in Providence that I'm
still kicking myself for not having
visited the one time I gave a talk in
Providence yeah but I know Eric liked
you very quickly and that was really one
of them in New York were the main places
that that he lived over the course of
his life Providence through most of it
and his father exits his life fairly
quickly by the time that he's three his
father has a great gets
institutionalized in a smaller hospital
which Lovecraft's families would have a
pretty bad relationship with over time
already by that time the Lovecraft is a
very bright precocious boy starts
reciting poetry memorizing it he
actually wrote a lot of poetry in
employment I have to admit I haven't
wrapped more than just a bit of his
poetry so I'm more interested in the
stories and essays but he he wrote an
awful lot he felt that poetry was quite
important begins writing poems by the
time that he's six and by the time of
the greatest father dies so its father
has been out of his life you know
whatever the campaing is his mother
moved him and with their grandfather and
two aunts so he has a sort of some
paternal example in the place and
Lovecraft begins attending this later
having in school but he's not gonna last
long there
get pulled out due to his ill health and
he encounters one of the people he's
going to really influence him Edgar
Allan Poe another great horror writer
and one of the first reading one first
passages that I have for here mr. self
that is actually his assessment of Poe
so we'll come back to that in just a bit
well he starts producing his own
magazines by the time that he's dying
and so the first one is this scientific
exact please clearly somebody who is is
very creative also very practical very
interest within astronomy in science and
this one's of course at a time where you
know science is making these great
advances this kind of clash going on
between more traditional ways of looking
at the world and the modern scientific
way of looking at it
he also starts on a journal of astronomy
and then some catastrophe happens when
his grandfather dies the mismanagement
of the estate ends up with with him well
the whole family having to move into a
smaller house this is sort of the
beginning of a long series of setbacks
but they're going to happen he also gets
a start in writing not just thing that
he's sort of churning out himself but in
you know a journal by sending in a
letter on astronomy to this Providence
Sunday German he's he's correcting
people who got things wrong and they
invite him to do some work writing which
he does you know you did anything about
this he'd be the kid who was showing
that he's got some some intelligence and
some talent he ends up having a nervous
breakdown
unfortunately doesn't finish high school
is not able
to enter Brown University in feces is
major setback to his life and then he
starts publishing other things he
published this letter to the acceptance
of a pulp magazine Argosy gets published
and again he's working essentially as a
literary critic he is invited to join
this United amateur Press Association
and this is going to start opening up
doors for him and connecting him with
other people he starts going to
conventions and associations and he
starts people can tell what this guy
really can write and and he starts to
get you know offers to do things you
notice from this point on we had all
these stories published welcome never
publishes an album in the course of his
life he publishes the feeling of dollars
but he never writes anything that would
be novel like almost all of this is
published in you know what we now call
Paul and while they called it back then
and these were these are magazines that
were why do they call Pope because they
were on the cheapest paper possible so
that they could be super cheap for
people to buy a lot of what was going
into these is not a particularly high
quality we get a phone so they had a bad
reputation to follow them appeal to you
know sort of baser instincts something a
lot of true crime stuff works was
pulping and if you ever seen any Szold
true crime things the covers are very
lurid you know it's not enough just
definitely strangling somebody if
there's a woman involved you probably
see a good portion of the chest
you know we complain about comic book
people how they draw heroines at this
time is the same sort of weird gyrations
you know a lot of blood you know a lot
of sensationalism going on
and so the Lovecraft is you know she's
not writing he's he's writing Greek
literature but he's not writing a forum
that's really devoted to great
if he time if if his goal was to write
literature with a capital L he would be
you know sending off the other journals
were paper costs more and you know it's
got a higher sort of level of clientele
you're not seeing in the drugstores yeah
is there a break here am i
misunderstanding was he his early
writing I mean for scientific as ed in
astronomy and that sounds like
nonfiction like science yeah I mean so
then by the time he gets up to what age
23 or something or 33 20 spot on honey
for Argosy is obviously you touch yeah
and I think it was you know you know so
he makes a big switch here but we don't
know why well he likes writing stories
he continues I I don't have any like his
nonfiction on here all I did is pretty
well I mean buddy grading for an IV or
coaching or editing or whatever I don't
know he's all the Magnificat Dennis yeah
yeah there's no break it's just fused
writing across the board he's writing
scientific stuff sort of popular science
stuff he's writing stories she's writing
poetry on the timeline again all I did
was put his stories but he's got all
sorts of other layers it is really
conservative is that no not a science
publication that's that yeah that's well
that's a worm okay I want to me let it
be call it a nonfiction yeah yeah a
cultural you know cultural and political
stuff yeah it was just to me another
break yeah you can say well we have a
different road times I don't know I
don't know that's fine I mean he's just
like I think you can see it less is a
break and more of a adding something to
the repertoire sort of like somebody
like a musician who starts up playing
piano and now they ought they play piano
and guitar
and now they played piano guitar and the
trombone you know there's nothing being
it would get break if he like never did
the other stuff again but he continues
writing some things throughout the
course it was like he can get paid for
writing the palm stuff not well if I
know nobody was I suppose the editors
are probably making decent money on it
and the owners but the writers weren't
but I think there was more money in
doing that sort of thing
any-any clearly liked writing these
sorts of stories but it but he does
write a lot of you know what we would
call creative nonfiction essays you know
responding at the time so like during
the the First World War he you know he
writes some some things had to do with
war
he he writes literary reviews of
different people so yeah he's very
prolific I I said then I mostly just
read the stories and some of the essays
and a few of the poems I'm not really a
big poetry guy first up the heat though
but let's go on and so let go of this he
he actually tries it last in the
National Guard but he's a terrible
health so it fails a physical eventually
his mother gets committed to what
l'hospital then Lovecraft encounters one
of his next major literary influences is
more Duensing who got another passage
about him in there and his mother's
going to die in that same hospital with
a failed gallbladder operation I guess
back back that was kind of a risky
venture and not long after that that
Lovecraft meets this this woman Sonya
green she's from New York she's going to
end up living
in other places as well and they click
very quickly she is kind of take-charge
person he's more of a dreamer you know
although he could get some things done
but she is much more practical than he
is and his two aunts are very surprised
but how quickly he connects up with her
and then decide that they're going to
get married where they're against it he
marries her he ends up moving to New
York to live with her for for a short
time while he's in New York he ends up
you know in some degree of poverty
things start out fairly good and then
they start to go downhill and by the end
he's living in a tenement and Red Hook
subsiding out whatever he can he can eat
Sonia has gone elsewhere to look for
work in Cleveland and eventually he
decides to move back to Provence
it doesn't appear interesting the sheets
you write earlier on and she wrote a bit
about you know their life together
she said that he performed
satisfactorily you know his husbandly
duties but but not you know superbly or
anything like that he was competent
because you can say almost worse than
incompetent
yeah well you know it's a live at the
time you know they're probably
incompetent or up claps can I come in
and sort of more openness about that but
she you know she she's sort of on the
move and they're they're managed really
it's not much of a March for a good
portion of it and eventually she she
decides you know they should get
divorced and he's okay with that they
had an amicable divorce she finds out
after he dies he never signed the papers
and she got married in the meantime lose
everything yeah
so unfortunately they didn't they didn't
like you know check up on this sort of
thing they went from noticing give you
the very productive during these years
he moves back to Providence he's also
engaged with a whole lot network of
other writers some of whom you could say
are his peers and then some of who are
you might tell such as protégées or he's
he's helping them out he's doing what we
would nowadays I suppose call coaching
so there's a lot of correspondence
between him and other authors some of
whom you know might might surprise you
like Robert Howard write slipping on
econia books he and well crafted a very
strong connection Derleth of course and
he's not very old you know he's uh 47
when he dies of cancer the small
intestine and apparently swelling in the
kidneys he won't go to the doctor and he
ends up you know dies as a result he
leaves behind some other manuscripts
that do get published later and put that
in the timeline so I want to just keep
it one page but there's some others that
weren't published by then and you know
in his lifetime I guess you could say he
was recognized by his fans and he was
recognized by the other writers who he
was influencing but he didn't have
anything like the almost cult status
that he has today so typical story of
you know we often talk to well artists
only become famous after they die that
really is the case with Lovecraft and
his works you know the value that they
have I mean if he had been around today
I suppose he would have realized a lot
of wealth from his writing but he didn't
get that in his own time any money you
know his last year apparently he was in
terrible pain much of the time but still
right
so that's that's his biography it kind
of a sad story isn't it of this guy
let's talk about the universe that he
creates so now let's start actually
getting right into philosophical things
because we're talking about cosmology
Lovecraft I think it's safe to say
throughout all these stories the only
characters that are generally going to
be recurring are non-human bad guys
these godlike creatures the elder things
or great old ones somebody called the
Elder Gods those are recurring in this
but most of the stories will be about
one person or set of people
it usually engaged in some sort of
exploration or research project or
trying to stop some terrible calamity
that they realize is about to happen and
we don't pick up with them afterwards so
in a way it's sort of like you know when
we did in banks and the culture series
and it's the culture itself was the
thing that held everything together I
suppose you could say that about about
Lovecraft himself well his story itself
so what is his universe like well it's
it's a universe in which human beings
are not particularly important and
certainly not anywhere near as important
as we make ourselves out to be where our
theories of how the universe itself got
started and what its history was like
are mostly wrong and the real story is
far more vast and cyclopean and terrible
than we could ever imagine and if we
could you know pierce the veil on it we
would probably go and sing and let me
actually read you one of the call sign
from the college of to research the
motive is how we begin the most merciful
thing in the world I think is the
inability of the human
I correlate all its contents immediately
the placid island of ignorance in the
midst of black seeds of infinity and it
was not meant that we should voyage far
the science is each training and film
direction and hitherto harmed us little
but someday the piecing together the
Associated knowledge will open up such
terrifying vistas of reality and of our
frightful position there in that we
shall either go mad from the revelation
or flee from the deadly light into peace
and safety of a new Dark Age so either
we would go just totally nuts or we
would burn all of our books and destroy
all of our apparatus so we can go back
to being primitive barbarians because at
least they thought they weren't troubled
by thoughts of how horrifying the
universe truly is and you know so why
did they say that sort of thing well you
know on the earth there is like a whole
prehistory that we discover in the
stories by encountering you know bits
and pieces of it all sorts of
intelligent races before us and we're
just sort of a blip some thought Verizon
and we develop science and that's really
cool but the science that we have is
just child's play compared to what these
other beings had and they weren't even
all on the same page you know there's a
sort of printed out a timeline here just
to try to keep it straight in my head he
has you know for example the universe
being created and we've got the planet
Earth formed and about a billion years
ago the elder things arrive on earth and
the elder things are one of these these
races and this is this is what we're
going to find out about in say the
novella at the mountains of madness
which is about Antarctica and they find
this vast you know ruined city where all
of the previous owners are either frozen
or dead and the creatures that they made
out of you know mock son
the shoggoths to do their work for them
at Guam crazy nor are doing their own
thing elder things spread across the
entire earth for a while they adapt to
land then we have another race the
flying polyps or any contact kind of
silly fun day they will start building
these giant basalt powers they get into
a war with the elder things Wars that
are on a scale of like in our great
world wars that we think about the
element of things start creating the
kind of life that we now see as part of
the evolutionary chain start making fish
they start making reptiles and things
like that then we get other other you
know races and creatures coming in the
great race of yet who can transport
their minds into other beings and that
that way avoid death we have the great
old ones coming down from from the stars
and by that we're talking about you know
Cthulhu this is horrifying
octopus mountainous creature
you know it's described in various
different ways who winds up being
worshipped in you know sort of areas of
the world like the Eskimos offer up in
you know Greenland making statues to him
and you know voodoo cult getting
associated with it I mean Lovecraft is
drawing answer the at knology available
to Mecca pine but he's leaving this this
story in which there's so much more
going on behind the scenes that we could
possibly be aware of and that's just you
know like sort of the big picture then
there's you know stories where a painter
for example likes to paint ghouls and
these Google creatures do exist down
down in the you know
the sewers and subways and catacombs and
it's kinda there's a little story
pickman's model Pikmin is able to do
these really vivid scary paintings of
ghouls in part because he actually uses
real ghouls this is his artist model and
it's even more terrifying creatures down
there so in all these - the phrase that
Lovecraft likes to employ eldritch
forces right now so there's you can say
well these must be understood it's like
fantasy or supernatural horror stuff one
crafted is done that makes sense to call
science fiction because he's saying this
is all scientific it's just a science
that's much further advanced of the
science that that we know so Cthulhu
coming down from the stars or these
other creatures coming down from from
space there if they're actually relying
on an understanding of the universe that
go that eclipses our own understanding
of the universe they understand how to
make their way through space and time
they understand how to open up gaps
between stars or different dimensions
they have a better understanding when
they create their cities or create other
places it you know the architecture
itself reflects a again another freight
if you want non-euclidean you know job
geometrical way of understanding things
I think nowadays if we take geometry
classes
we're not sold so you know enthused
about that word value Clinton because we
learn you know very early on in a
college geometry class that Euclid was
actually just one way of looking at the
world there's other other ways of
understanding the relationship between
parallel lines and all that but for them
this is at this time this is sort of
like you know a scary concept there are
you know our notions of space and time
is being something constant that we can
rely upon that was what Lovecraft is
with being shaken so I would say I don't
know it's hard to estimate this how many
of the characters meet terrible atoms in
Lovecraft stories probably a good 50% of
them after they communicate to us what
they had to tell us about you know the
horrors that they're saying so we only
you know it's a narrative world that we
get to see piece by piece there are some
constants so I mentioned you know these
great beings right better almost beyond
our comprehension there's also a
literature and a lore that Lovecraft
will appeal to in story after story he's
the guy came up with the rope you know
the word in Necronomicon so we that made
its way into pop culture now and people
envision it as a book that's got like
you know an eye on it or teeth there's
something like that it's bound with
somebody's flash you open it up and
terrible things happen right
so if evil dad used book the Australia
will be Dead Alive used as well if I'm
not mistaken I need a navy mistake
exactly they get kids getting recycled
so the Necronomicon was supposed to it's
supposed to be this book written by this
man Arab who actually you know
encountered these cosmic beings and it
drove him insane he wrote things down
and it was translated into various
languages and so you know fortunately we
possess the one in Latin by tribal
members names and last name is warming
us and so there's books like that and
then walk at makes up location still a
lot of myrrh new england like Miskatonic
University which has a Necronomicon and
and you've got and then the first of the
cool myth of stuff that other people
write using this is long so you know the
Miska the Miskatonic University is on
this
town of River which doesn't of course
exist but you could imagine existing
somewhere in there England and there's
all these other places that you've got
are constants in this universe and the
Spirit of the universe so that's
probably enough about about the
narrative universe before we go into
these philosophical themes any any
comments or reactions or things you want
to get on particularly struck you
rereading or reading or craft things you
found infuriating puzzling this world
you're talking about it is recurring
throughout its work oh yeah some some
some of the stories more than others so
there is I should also mention there's a
set of stories that wind up being set in
other places that that don't exist more
fantasy oriented ones like you know what
about the cats of booth R which is very
interesting that's a more fantasy story
less horror story except for I guess the
two people who live that people who got
eaten by the cats so there's there's
places like that once there was written
in Lovecraft can invoke them or not
invoke them usually it's only the
connections are always a kind of a
distance like I heard this story about
such and such you know the fixed points
are things like this katana University
these these texts and the in some of
those stories is the primal creatures
that that run the show
they never give there's no story where
it gives us a revelation
so okay but it's like Falcor that county
he made up yeah I suppose
okay that could be an analogy yeah okay
yeah I saw in your thing it says the
underworld which one business which
which is very very good and I always
come here and figure it out
yeah you know I mean so some of the
stories are this is actually a place to
talk a bit about the evolution is
writing in this law so the Lovecraft
scholars and there's many of them out
there because people love writing on
love crime they've talked in terms of
three main phases of his work and the
first days she's kind of under the
influence of Poe and a lot of this is
really
juvenalian we call them our you know
serve in that vein so it wouldn't be bad
to like that despite talking about what
he says about focuses before politics
weird writers have work largely in the
dark without an understanding of a
psychological basis of the horror appeal
and hampered by more or less of
conformity to certain empty literary
conventions such as the happy ending
virtue of warding virtually rewarded
then general Howell moral didacticism
acceptance of popular standard of values
and the striving of the author took true
to his own emotions in the story and
take the size of partisans of the
majority's artificial ideas those
typical Lovecraft writing Geordie they
if they only knew what things were
really like you know they wouldn't be so
so sanguine polo on the other hand
perceive the essential in personality of
the real artist knew that the function
of creative fiction is merely to express
and interpret events and sensations that
they are regardless of how they tender
what they prove good or evil attractive
or repulsive stimulating and pressing
with the author always acting as a vivid
and detached chronicler
rather than as a teacher sympathizer
vendor of opinion so what's the result
of this he says host factors acquired a
convincing malignity possessed by no
there
censors and established a new standard
of realism the annals of literary horror
the impersonal and artistic intent was
aided by a scientific attitude that
often found before whereby posted human
mind rather than usages of gothic
fiction and worked with an analytical
knowledge of terrorist resources which
doubled the force of his narratives and
emancipated it from all the absurdities
inherited merely conventional shutter
clicks so st. Paul has really
accomplished something new and INE
follows along with that so some of them
some of his early writings would be
fitting into into that sort of sequence
so you know like the raft in the wall I
would say are kind of along those those
line ringing conventional shutter
courting oh you know following along the
the conventions of the writers before
that we're trying to produce this you
know fear fear effect we are using to
sort of cliche understand
yeah said a coin yeah have you been
useful engine and I said nearing
innovation we're going to be waxing
poetic don't care anymore so the
mercenary implication - oh you mean like
making money on shutting out people who
are just writing and they're going to
sell it I suppose but I think he's
talking more about like when we talk
about coining the phrase right here
requiring a shudder you're clearly
motion right there wait a minute put us
in a very stereotyped way right so
there's a sort of following along with
the old pal I'm just a sort of a
Christian who actually before we were
talking about the different world that
he set up and he use that came in and
the idea that you know mankind knew
whole that's why they were idiots that
it would just be too much and they all
go up and shoot themselves or something
yeah it sounds more like rather than
having a curiosity about it it was more
of a fear of everything so was it you
know what
you've been on one press-telegram yeah a
lot that he said he's trying to portray
to again and I don't and probably have
the right immediate ending system you
know obviously making something fiction
yeah and but was the idea to why I
mentioned the idea what was too
horrified because it wasn't you know I
mean he didn't seem to come off like
this like this is really look at how
great we can discover something through
these beings as a [ __ ] just like
atlases so horrible can't even imagine
yeah but it was it more just to keep
that whole idea of shudder a horror
going then than it was to have a
curiosity about this well whether it be
I mean some of the characters start out
one of the character arcs that you see
in quite a few of these is characters
who are curious about the occult or you
know antiquated things or things that
other people are paying attention to
right and so they start delving into it
then they start getting excited about
the discoveries that they're making a
lot of them are explorers or researchers
and they start to realize that they're
going in a little bit too deep and then
they start to find out what's really
loud Lisa portion what's really going on
sometimes they're actually like opposed
by other people who are in league with
these these dark forces right and by the
time you get to the end of most of those
stories they're in too deep and they're
not going to get out and either they've
gone insane or they left behind a you
know one of Lovecraft's favorite devices
is I found this this story that somebody
wrote down a football because that way
you have a character who like you know
meet their end and all that but yeah so
you can say you know the curiosity
doesn't kill the cat but it leads the
cat into the whole set of traps and
those traps are finding out how
you know how bad things actually are it
would polka tea didn't really cut up
world room and he just face it because
just his writings were more corny with
the story and what happened there's some
this world for you and randomly it was
you know yeah whether you mean tickle
potential harder the real captain must
allow any look at it's a story focusing
on something that's a horrific act as
can be happening to these people and
after or whatever so um but listen so I
don't because I don't even remember much
I've been somewhat correct years and
years ago remember how much of it was
but I don't remember the but just when
you were talking about the fact that
leave this world and it just seemed like
he was only perpetrating that to induce
again appear in horror rather than like
this is something that could be well
okay well or for just be I'm just go
back to the paragraph you read before
you for pulling and working wrote
effective and insane but it says that
the function is boy yet what is the trim
off that time so yeah so he's saying you
know the funk
this is his view and that the function
of creative fiction is Miller to
expressing interpretive and sensations
as they are yeah it's perceived William
regardless of whether they tend to be
good or evil attractive or repulsive
stimulating or depressant so he's chosen
people repulsive expressing as quit
crying I don't think you trying just
yeah you could yeah you're right he
could just as well and have taken
uplifting stories you know rather than
yeah because another quote from
Lovecraft is that one of the oldest and
strongest at human emotion that's re
begins on a Saracen araga source of fear
is fear of the unknown
yeah so that sort of seemed to drive his
what was that that's it was hanging an
obsession he perceived any I'm not
keeper duty truth it's writing he's
trying to get more of the unknown is
being fearful rather than asking
something to Authority curious and you
know another theme that comes up too and
he talks about this in
two other essays some notes on nonentity
and that notes on writing weird fiction
he says that part of what's going on in
a rear tail is that you suspend sort of
fixed cosmic law or order that we we
tend to rely upon and you can do that
disability 50% displease well you cannot
yet so if your yeah yours and your
suspending disbelief specifically in in
this that things could somehow just be
different than we think that they are so
you know you think about the advancement
that were being made by Science and
Technology in his time and the fact that
they you know before before you know the
massive world war loses faith in
progress going on all the time
Lovecraft in writing the Weird Tales and
saying well what if our notion of things
was radically flawed what if there isn't
the predictability or continuities what
is that sort of like that the surface
level that that we like to think is the
case you can see actually now that I
think about it one of the shows do you
guys remember this show from the 1970s
and early eighties called tales from the
darkside mm-hmm remember how the intro
went it was really quite smart I mean
the effects are really hokey cuz it was
at that time it's yeah you know the idea
was mankind you know pays attention to
this bright lit world on surface but you
know there's also this this dark side
just this other world and that's just as
real how does it go it's just as real
but not as brightly lit I think
well I used to watch this I get you I
mean I watched you try when they're out
you're seeing the real girl young boy
that anybody in that idea of you know
we're we're not really getting so he's
doing this to fiction he's creepy that
the butcher really think that the world
was a world of which Cthulhu exactly I
think so right but but is it is it you
know possible that maybe the world is
much different than than what you know
modern science tells us but there is a
proponent of an idea or a concept rather
than a detach chronicler because over
here for he wrote the word hey I am NOT
absolutely karim appetizer of interval
anything about Paul yeah but both ideas
this is remember this is an essay to us
very long about supernatural horror and
literature impose one of the people at
the start yeah I mean maybe I mean what
crafts done I don't think things that
could food will exists right well maybe
in the unconscious or different world
right well they're they're really
archetype of it is done yeah well so
that was the case well that would be
very interesting because that would mean
that we would have an archetype of
something that's just you know primal
horror that it would be an archetype of
something that we wouldn't be able to
come to terms with right and that would
be part of our put this inheritance
alien being I mean this is a given
universities time is timing on it if
there is is fundamental for yeah and
ugliness then we create the opposite to
keep that at bay well or we I mean one
don't worry John or we don't know about
or we don't know about it most of the
time because we live and that yeah that
we'll have because we have to have some
semblance as well order and meaning and
you could not live in and complete well
what craft stories that's what a problem
for 99
population they've got order in meaning
it just happens to be that the wood is
the press the repulsive society well
they don't need to for until they
actually encounter that sort of thing I
mean so one of the stories that he's got
that's kind of interesting for talking
about this is about this old man who he
encounters in you know sort of the
backwoods of New England and your
interest he's an antiquarian riding on a
bicycle he wants to see these old
farmhouses then they go then and he
finds us this old man who found
apparently he's been living for more
than a hundred years and he's got this
book that he traded with you know sea
captain and he can't read it it's all in
Latin but it's got these pictures in it
we're supposed to be Africans but they
they're action white and they're
butchering human beings and eating it
the old man you know the old man is
talking about how he gets a cat tickle
he looks at this picture you know and of
course you know the guy realizes it's
pretty quickly I'm going to get the hell
out this year and and fortunately
lightning strikes the building and you
know the collapse and we think it gets
out of there before the old man can can
turn them into death but what's going on
there well you've got these it so you
know if we're talking about like the
world of you know the metropolis
terrible things can happen right when
there's some sort of generation there's
crying and stuff in that and that's how
you counter that waffle side of life but
again you know isolated into the
backwoods of New England and now there
is this this tendency for human beings
to Canada generate and they're they're
coming into contact with with these
things so the further we get from
whatever counts with civilization you're
right there there's this thing that has
to be kind of dealt with you know and so
in some of the cases have dealt with by
these terrible forces you just worship
them you become
there there blog thank you they're
stronger than you so you know that's one
way to deal with it and then you know
you know the next words watch tells
people they have no idea just how bad
things actually are and I guess the
implication is you know we could have a
civilization where most of the people
are kind of in the dark about this just
they go and I force the habit either you
know they they follow traditional
religion which is according to one print
that's on Punk or they have faith in
science and in science works but if we
follow science off that I would enough
and we're really scientific about things
where they're starting countering things
that make us feel queasy and and scared
and upset you know so yeah I mean that's
one of the things I want to talk about
is the different kinds of weird tail
welcome don't you have these other
stories where there it's not war and all
it's more fantasy so why not have that
other side and the energies he's really
the second guy that he talks about I
will read through all of this but he
talks about more devastating and he says
Denison was an adventure of a new
mythology and Weaver of surprising
folklore he stands dedicated to a
strange world with fantastic beauty and
pleasure eternal warfare against the
coarseness and ugliness of diurnal
reality his point of view is the most
truly cosmic of any held in literature
the period the sensitive is posed to
dramatic values and the significance of
isolated words and details and far
better equipped rhetorically to a simple
lyric style based on the prose of the
King James Bible
this author that is done say drawers
with a tremendous effectiveness on every
body of myth and legend producing a
competent or eclectic cycle and so he's
talking about this you know productive
fantasizing and so some of these stories
like you know the silver key the castle
both are
don't be ranking on it just you have a
dream quest those are all in this
dynasty end period rivalries can under
his influence and then the Cthulhu stuff
that whole stuff comes comes later and
continues on to the end of his life so
the scholars see like a Poe influence
period of Dennis a influence period more
suit more fantasy stuff and then finally
a food period in which things are you
know essentially cosmic horror well this
is a good transition into talking about
science for Lovecraft or we can even go
expand further rationalism when we use
this word rationalism we're talking
about a confidence in human reason and
its capacities to figure out not just
what the universe is but how we ought to
live how we ought to orient our lives
what reality is how we can be in touch
with it and science you know since the
you know rise of a lot in sciences in
the you know the early modern period you
know from like the fifteen sixteen
hundreds onward has been the main way
that we do this and I would say I
suppose technology is also closely
connected as well and we still a lot of
people who have very very strong faith
that science will resolve all of our
issues this is kind of a a battle being
fought in our own culture today
you know the idol of science being
people you know great example what we
call scientism was view that science
will resolve all of our issues now it
turns out that when you actually start
doing science it's a lot messier than
pilots portray right and there's a lot
of setbacks and it's often not quite
clear precisely where the border between
science and other things begins
but someone crafts universe
interestingly a lot of his characters
are scientists of a sort and they are
committed to a essentially scientific
viewpoint on things and what they find
out is a the universe is more complex
than what our scientific viewpoints
we're able to take into account being
when we're able to apply science to
these new objects of study like color on
space or or something like that we we
wind up finding out more information but
that information doesn't always make
things better for us and see science
itself is you know it all gets presented
as if there's intrinsic good to knowing
realities and transit good to doing
science in the end science turns out to
be as for Lovecraft as meaningless as
any of the other activities that we
might be involved in meaning by that
that it's not giving us some sort of
primal connection to whatever is most
important what reveals to us instead is
how insignificant we are and doesn't
give us any guidance about what the hell
were supposed to do people like that you
know not only of science also gives us
technology and things that we can use to
sort you know keep the elder you know
beings or these terrible things at bay
right once we discover it but science
the other things say about science too
is welcome to understand that science is
not something that just the scientist
does it's like this continual process so
when some of the explorers discover make
these horrifying discoveries and then
close up what they found they know
somebody else is going to come along
try to follow up on it and then how do
they dissuade them from that once once
you've opened the gate it's hard to keep
keep other people back especially when
you're you know being motivated by the
bill their knowledge with the develop
our our grasp of the universe so there
is somebody else who is not a
contemporary of Lovecraft that perceived
him and we know that Lovecraft read it
we have a somewhat similar view on
science and that's Friedrich Nietzsche
Nietzsche thought that a lot of the
scientists that they called the men of
science were really just sort of the
newest incarnation of religious people
who we thought were fundamentally
mistaken they created value as they
created old systems of you know
mythologies and and ways of doing things
so that they could even had some order
in their life and everyone could you
know feel okay about what they were
doing in the universe it's basically you
know just predatory and you know for the
most part word words you know a little
bit of that universe
he said science and and you know the
Enlightenment and this whole rationalist
way of doing things it was just the
latest incarnation of that what he
called the aesthetic ideal that was
originally the priest and became a
philosopher and then fire them to the
scientist and he was if you were going
to be really scientific about things
then you would find out that human
beings and then the whole world was much
more terrible than you know the
scientists are making it out to be and
then there was less less natural order
and much more just things developing in
certain ways
you know there wasn't a lot of rhyme and
reason to it sure this is as you know in
each of these said truth is something
useful it's not something that has a
value in and of itself in common mobile
army of metaphors in one of his essays
which is already a metaphor of course
and so well perhaps you know it's not
clear exactly how influenced well craft
is by nature he's read nature he knows
people who read nature there were a lot
of missed readings of Nietzsche at the
time you know this whole notion of like
the Superman and all that
well craft doesn't seem to be that
interested in that idea he's more
interested in this is economic
implications of the universe that
doesn't have you know any sort of order
in it or if it does it's an order far
beyond our understanding not something
that our rationality can can absolutely
comprehend so you know there's this kind
of a double side to science because the
longer it progresses the more it gets us
into this troubling way of looking at
things so this is where the theme of
cosmic pessimism comes up so let's say
you find out that the universe is like
that let's say let's say you find out
that you know a lot of what you find
valuable can be explained in scientific
terms that those that explaining sucks
the very meaning out of the things that
you care about and even that science
itself is kind of shaky that there's
more going on in the universe than just
our human technology and science and
rationalism all this religious stuff
that people believe in is all nonsense
things start to look at it dismal
especially if you add to it that we're
not just like you know in the universe
where maybe there's no real meaning for
us but there are these horrifying
creatures that antedate us much more
intelligent than us who some of us are
worshipping and want to transform the
ways that would you know be catastrophe
for certainly our civilizations if not
all of us individually once you find out
stuff like that that sounds pretty bad
doesn't it so kind of a pessimistic view
the universe and there's been a lot of
interesting discussion of this Lovecraft
didn't really consider himself a
pessimist
you know pending this would be somebody
to say this is the worst of all possible
worlds like like Arthur Schopenhauer and
Lovecraft said no notes this is just an
indifferent universe it doesn't care
about us
certainly Ambrose Bierce is another
personal life along these lines you know
if it's a kind of universe that you know
whatever desires we have what other
whatever you know plans whatever
accounts we developed your science the
universe doesn't care one way or the
other so you know you couldn't eat in
some ways liberated more optimistic
about things well why in life is what
you make of it if you want to do science
go ahead and do science you know you
worship the elder beings go ahead and do
that right you want to just do artwork
and you know be influenced by you know
through through your dreams and make
some creative things about ghouls okay
just go ahead and do that too that's
that's nice you know but I guess I see
that philosophy in whatever work or
Xavier yeah from it is really um yeah I
just pessimistic but I mean turning to
the fear side and it comes maybe from
man setting himself apart above what
detached yeah well there's a whole
nother philosophy that would say if man
if humans felt themselves integrated
with the universe yeah they would want
to go with the flow but all this could
table that fatalism or that's whatever
but I guess it I think there's really
two different philosophies here
and I think we know we don't in the West
sea you know that much of the
alternative yet it's out there and I
think this form of view of the universe
and the function of religion or the
function of science
yeah-ha really comes from where the
person or the human race feels itself
set yeah is different and therefore when
there's something else big out there
that we don't grasp and understand that
we feel threatened because we've set
ourselves apart as opposed to having
communion with it being a part of it I
mean yeah I think I think I think you're
right that would be another option or or
you could just have a sense of law you
know or be almost like a cosmic tourist
what right but yeah yeah I think you got
some of my science fiction comes from
from movies yes you know more than
briefing at least unless whatever number
of years yeah so I I saw that the
Spielberg was really trying to cut a
different road with with the story BT
because a lot of science fiction and
then we'll get out of here like I am
closing out I mean but a lot of it
before that had really been a
threatening that's almost oh my god come
to be scared yeah it could have been a
modern-day Lovecraft sort of like Olivia
yeah I mean so but they were trying to
break free and says maybe there's this
wonderful peaceful you know much more
pleasant we have a look more
optimistically and be part of this
rather than set ourselves differently
and so I think that was a real different
sort of science fiction it yeah I would
call science fiction no I think you're
right and I think I think you're you
know different glasses your worldviews
universities yeah I mean what I think
song and sauce is you know they're very
long time we have this optimist realist
debate in a multiple groups of people on
saying I'm not I'm not a pessimist right
I don't realize yeah
I mean the activists when they're
accused of being unduly optimistic will
sometimes say things like that too and
probably they are in sensible realist
because they are usually picking out
aspects of situations that the other
side isn't isn't seeming right that you
usually they go run by insisting too
strongly on how their side is kind of
totally right the insides got kind of
totally hot ready and and yeah well that
could have gone differently and in a few
of the stories you don't go a different
way though the stories that are more
influenced by Laura gonna see and our
you know sort of straight out fantasy
where the people are going to these cool
locations and witnessing these wonderful
things and there is you know some
horrible eldritch terror in the back
that's going to come in and crash
anything once you've got something like
a fool you know on the aural whole top
of one of these other elder you know or
old ones on the scene it's off it's all
bad and you got to figure out where
you're going to place yourself are you
going to get into them like so you know
having sort of communion with them
communion with some being whose mind we
can't comprehend and who just seems to
want to consume us well then that seems
kind of it and that's more like you know
alien right that whole sequence almost a
movie with solid I'm six months ago and
I think of the name of it was a woman
who is a survival thing yeah right yeah
I mean oh that was a darling we're in a
very non verbal sense yeah people on
earth had no idea is little bit blopps
totally threatening we're going to drop
nukes on them and everything yeah yeah
there was an intelligence there and
there was this great struggle I need a
really good storyline
yeah well very well done yeah I did it
shows that that narrative is just as
possible as aliens or Independence Day
or whatever it is it's a bad guy then it
could be something silly like that one
with the Martian
the brains been on regular track coming
to steal the women Mars Attacks right
yeah I mean that's still in that same
genre well if we if we know that those
Martians are such bastards we would have
had to you know oppose the constructive
thing on a wall mr. document constructs
because we can't go in you're right yeah
you know we can't go anywhere else I
mean everything that we come up with is
all we can do is all you know I mean
well just a human coaster again what
yeah you're probably going in the
collective unconscious oh oh I know how
we plug into things that are totally you
cannot begin to explain yet there is
yeah a commonality of communication
across time in place
certainly and things come up order to be
patterns and images and then blended in
the stories are song and so we are
reaching a parting to other species is
not that big of a job you know on maybe
elf bacteria all around us is just as
intelligent and informative for us what
we sorta don't think about it well it's
interesting because the more that we're
finding out in our own time we should
you know keep in mind that our
scientific understanding of universes
far advanced beyond out of the time
Lovecraft
you know we're discovering things like
the symbiotic relationship between us
and our bacterial flora alright and how
important that is
I mean it's definitely Lovecraft
couldn't have conceived up and we have
you know the other thing to think about
too
now we're getting quite far away from
Lovecraft it's just how much resources
we have to devote to doing that kind of
research compared to back back then you
know we have so many more people on the
problems you could say that
so maybe maybe these are difference or
narrative well they would have mansion
the things that we're just not finding
out about - I mean some of that they
have the collective unconscious that
somehow within the imagination like some
of a terrible universes with string
theory how many people were talking
about heroin universes and now that
that's coming for flourishing the string
theory and stuff like that so I think at
some point there's something there in
the imagination you notice about that
later on become scruples and it goes
back to an openness of mind in terms of
approaching the other I hear ganas like
against the other because it's going to
undercut or threaten me yeah okay so
let's let's talk them one of the themes
that comes up with Lovecraft and I don't
think this I don't think this fully
explained but why is the other
terrifying I don't think it goes all the
way there but it is something that's
really clear in its work is you could
call it a racialist mentality and in a
sort of you know prioritizing of the
angle over over everybody does you know
the other Europeans can be completely
degenerate - right
you know Spaniards a Frenchman Nolan
they are they get a watch out for them
but good angle stock is is going to come
for something I mean what craft is is is
writing in a time when a racism where
the scientific veneer - it was pretty
deeply rooted in in the culture the 19th
century had given rise to this very
strong America very strong in in England
in Germany as well and he I mean over
and over again
he's got characters so I guess you could
say there's there's like all these other
people's right and they're definitely
not European and so they they're
probably there's not much culture there
you know whatever culture they have is
still primitive it's still within the
realm of religion they don't have any
real science that they did then they'd
start behaving like a civilized people
in the notion right and they look back
to the identity at the time yeah and
then finally the Arizona was looking an
hour maybe even then called manifest
destiny material wealth and we just did
vanity of things in terms of when they
generated material wealth well and he
and he is writing from Yankee town yeah
I could mean because he's you know he's
in New England and he is from that that
stock and you see the since uh legit
stories where he talks about like these
immigrants coming in you know like those
Italians you know or or even even darker
people with more incomprehensible topics
you know and it's over and over and over
and over again throughout its works it's
like a constant fixture and you know
does that go somewhat to explaining this
fear of the other this notion that the
other trends your culture that you're
the apex of humanity and everything else
is sort of downhill and you can't do
very much with all of those people I
think it doesn't someone to take
something threatens their identity their
wealth their have their well-being their
xenophobia yeah yeah a lot I don't know
but it goes all the way to explain why
the whole universe would be populated by
you know who's these beings like I was
off is blind pulsating like stars
something at the center of things around
which all these lesser gods keep court
piping in the same
I mean that was I don't know I was done
funny actually he picked it up from him
oh we have sons and he has a sort of
sabor man and he ate God at the center
of the world who sleeping to a cosmic
Piper ever wakes up our universe pops
like a bubble because we're just a dream
well they're not done to the insertion
of cosmic pessimism it's a bit more
later yeah I mean I don't think you can
get back from racism right no matter how
hard you try because what would race
have anything that's about your cosmic
beings but I did but I think a lot of a
lot of you know he there's a fear - of
miscegenation right and for example the
shadow over Innsmouth we have these
people that thread with these sea
creatures and eventually the narrator
actually found out that he himself is
from that family - you have to go under
the sea to be with them
but if you know a lot of the
commentators think this reflects the
sort of fears about rates mixing at the
time and a lot of people have which were
you know pretty I mean when you read
some of the stuff that these people
thought would happen when you mix races
it sounds pretty pretty awful and you're
like where did you get these how would
you get these ideas you know especially
there's common experience of seeing
people who were fixed rates and they
they turned out okay you know so I'm
sorry I came out of their sense of
religion yeah okay there's one true
religion Christian white three-engine
and you know all of these fall aside
your subservient I mean however you want
to communicate I mean that that's where
it came from I think yeah not nothing
that would be original message I mean
but that's it over time for material
gains get that time
yeah and and you know I mean Lovecraft
rejects all that because Judaism
Christianity is bunk
you know but I think he was influenced
the one thing that's kind of interesting
is even being the right race doesn't
mean that you won't to generate for well
craft you know so you have these very
Anglo characters and they actually
worried like Lovecraft was I mean think
about his family the other things people
were very worried about the time is if
you had somebody in your family what
insane you're probably tainted and you
can alternate I mean that came out of
the religion do you know we're really
sick you're on the bad side of that I
mean because you did something although
the notion of like ancestral sin or
something I suppose yeah you don't want
to be interesting to me in offense just
a sidebar yeah if you took I mean this
is all Western world if you took
somebody in China educated whatever born
in 1899 age 47 or whatever okay and who
is a writer who had some sense of their
Industrial Revolution and development
whether it came from the wasps or came
from within their five years okay a
health care and development what how
would that contrast and see the
authority everything there's a Chinese
world out there five thousand years that
we are just totally oblivious we want to
keep it the end again no but every when
I think back at this time to do a
contrast with a love doctor say if
they're forcing the same questions about
the validity of past culture religion
world order universal view whatever as
really is well yeah how did it how do
you say Communist agricultural implement
let me kind of an interesting Chinese
science fiction Idaho times whether we
don't know about it look you can look at
that well I mean there were I mean one
thing that we'd have to deal with is the
fact that China went into massive
disorder there's we have this person
right more in 1890 and dicing it's
probably a bit I'm resigned to think
there was any continuity but there
probably wasn't but well I mean they I
mean they were being influenced by the
West right the technology was developing
the right dams much longer vaster
history behind them but there was like a
struggle going on for
you know what what is what is China it
was political it was intellectual
unfortunately it ends up in the Chinese
Civil War you know which took Locke a
lot of lives and then you know by the
time that we're taking about 37 Japan
are those are China - yeah I don't know
enough about Chinese literature to even
really speculate
I mean contemporary 20th century Chinese
literature I know I know bits and pieces
about you know classical Chinese with a
chair but that that would make me
competent to hit think about what the I
mean maybe there was a Chinese Lovecraft
you know or correspondent to them you
know it'd be quite interesting to think
about the the other thing that I was
going to talk about and we just have a
few minutes before they're going to
probably want to kick us out is this
notion of the indescribable that
Lovecraft plays with over and over again
it's always dicey to say that something
is unimaginable or indescribable or
something like that
in literature because you are already
describing it by calling it in
describing there's a paradox right the
way that language works I think that
love I personally think that Lovecraft
is a pretty good job in in like I said
going up to the limit and then that
going further in talking about you know
how these beings or cities or whatever
you want to describe what they're why
and that's part of the aspect of horror
as well
a lot of people think that if you went
far too too far on that and that his
writing is terrible
as a result and he has a story I don't
think it's been they're the ones that
I've got here I think it's called the
indescribable
a mobile the oven and walk yo crab yeah
if done friend who is making fun of them
as a writer for making too often
recourse to the unnameable and then its
friend of courses you know this is a
very scientific guy and eventually
encounters the ma the boat has to a
degree that it truly possible well what
kind of indicator they literally wake up
in a hospital room with weird bruises
and scars I wanted look at box scoops on
his face but there's no other sign of a
box being present is it I just like yeah
whatever it was it was indescribable
yeah feeling more people survive to the
end to because I mean think about what
it was well craft doing there he is he's
uh you know he's telling us critics you
know this my my use of this language
really is justified so I guess you know
there's kind of an interesting paradox
there he could have a sense of humor
about it yeah there's not a lot of humor
again no stories now in his nonfiction
he did see parodies that's true yeah I
imagine he must have been I don't know
that much about his like biography
biography like people saying what what
he was like as a person I imagine he
must have had a kind of fighting sense
of humor otherwise you've been pretty
glum to the to view us well I don't have
any other remarks myself believe it
certainly talk more - did you like to
order you know if you've got any
questions I can answer them as best as I
can you know yeah sure where should I
like because like I'm interested in off
is very long yeah where should I start
yeah just like a psalm thirty yes an
interesting coin
as an epic quest yeah so he's been in
volatize so many times and not only
anthology have exactly the same story
right these are some nice them that I
bought here at half price right but I
want to achieve you know I wanted to
have some Lovecraft around and these
aren't bad but you really you could just
get anything from the library that's why
I love craft that has some of the
stories and just start working your way
through them I don't think that one has
to remove in any sort of order you know
because they don't they don't they're
not you know sound like reading you're
going to read the Song of Ice and Fire
we better go over Game of Thrones right
now don't don't stir you know with the
fifth block because you're not going to
understand Tampa what's 12 so it is
going on yeah well you didn't even after
you have read the first book that one is
still a little confusing at times
because there's just too many characters
it's not a not a narrative universe like
that where you've got all that
continuity looking at his biography
considering all the horrible things that
happened to his family pretty early on
in his life but you asking around
general do you think that so this is
world view yeah yeah so we have a darker
Sun idea I mean it's
Stanwell to an institution diet before
should use 10 his mom yeah right around
when he she gets a dirty and goes the
same hospital yeah this dad fell the guy
and guess what a guy that a family gets
tossed into the street itself like well
they had to go to a smaller house so
they they weren't like totally destitute
others from that thousand eggs are wrong
some of his stories generator which
happens throughout the whole yeah people
and people usually we're taking the
place because of the bargain yeah we
exactly hope so yes it's with its folks
with them it was placed on the head when
we be talking about the happy stories of
age you know I you want to keep I think
it was not just that I think it's also
that you you couldn't really talk with
other people that you were used to
talking with about these sorts of things
you didn't want to anyone able to know
that your dad gone great right now
so who can you talk about other than
among family members some of them may be
going crazy than Falls or would be like
no no that's a single child
no silly yeah that makes it different
okay yeah it's simple you're right I
mean there's a lot of security miss like
them and I think that's I know how they
married on the slide is for some trying
to find some kind of security and it
just seems like you sure you realize
you're pulling kids right into it's just
you know yeah boys with it for four
years or one incredible part well you
put water is gone for good
flowers it yeah we made well at least
she said he performed satisfactorily so
they were intimate at one time
physically yeah amazing Hollywood they
traveled we get along well with his the
people he wrote what he came to do
better in writing yeah person yeah these
are people is very good Arthur me oh
he's awesome okay he's a Welsh writer
from the turn of the century and
speculation speculative fiction of kind
of weird fiction the Great God pan is
about brain surgery gone wrong my
sister's riding her poor old thesis on
it so long
he also wrote a bit about World War one
the terror sort of a suspense story that
might have might have supernatural
he's pretty fun
the brain three cheerleaders the Great
God pan yeah no the brain surgery opens
up like understanding we have too much
and yellow husband calling supernatural
horror literature his essay is really
great for an overview with the writers
she's like yeah it's this recommendation
is written before people end up not
liking of crap fun I'm going to do it
actually you can find mono Lovecraft
stuff online that's a good question
because it went to the public domain in
I am and you can find it
he decided red leader box to public's
claims to why people game oh my big TV
show yeah you have to pay anybody
another state to pay commission I
shoppers yeah but it also explains why
why there's so many a theology because
you know you can anybody can
anthologized public domain stuff right
so if we want to put together they're
welcome the best of Lovecraft according
to all of us
[Music]
you
[Music]